- Andrei has a glass tank.
First, he wants to put some marbles in it,
all of the same volume.
Then, he wants to fill the tank with water
until it's completely full.
This is the formula
for the volume of water
Andrei should use W, measured
in liters, as a function
of the number of marbles used n.
And we see that the amount
of water he needs to put in
as a function of the marbles used, n,
is equal to 32 minus 0.05n.
That's interesting.
Complete the following sentences
with the appropriate missing values.
The glass tank's volume is blank liters.
The volume of each marble is blank liters.
So, one thing that we could do
to think about the glass tank's volume is,
is well, let's use this
function to figure out
how much water would we need
if we had no marbles in it,
because that amount of
water would be the volume
of the entire tank.
Remember, we're gonna fill
up the entire tank with water
based on how many marbles are
in it, but if we figure out
what W of zero is, this is
the amount of water we need
if we had no marbles.
This would be the volume
of the entire tank
and what is this going to be?
Well W of zero, when n is equal
to zero, this term goes away
and we're left with 32.
So, W of zero would be
volume of entire tank.
Volume of tank, which
is equal to 32 liters
and so, we could write
32 right over there.
And then they ask us,
the volume of each marble
is blank liters.
Well, what's going on here
in this function definition?
So, the highest that this could be is 32,
'cause that's the most
water you would put in.
If you had no marbles, you
would just fill up the tank
and put in 32 liters.
Then, every marble that you put in,
you're going to have to
put in 0.05 less liters.
You see that, you have minus 0.05 times n.
So, every time n grows by one,
you have to put in 0.05 less
fewer liters of water,
which implies that the
marble is 0.05 liters.
That's it's volume, so let's
write that down, 0.05 liters.
And, you could test this assumption.
If you said, look, if you had one marble,
if you had one marble, then you would have
to put 0.05 less than 32 liters in
and why would that be the case?
Well, that would mean because
that one marble is taking up
0.05 liters, that's how
much space it's taking up.